so that is crazy so they like in terms
of we got to get to the elephant in the
room you know what a lot of people
consider one of the top zombie games
would be like a you know could die in
light and all that comparison so like
we you said visually nothing ain't
touching it but what about the sandbox
and the things that I like sandbox or
dying lights better okay okay but
after you get over the fact that you
can't jump over every little nook and
cranny like that's in the game and you
start to like really put yourself in
that Island too and not Dying Light you
start to like real like okay you know uh
I will say the combat
and Dead Island is better than the
combat and Dying Light also because I
feel like okay yeah because I I felt in
control for the most part when I was
doing stuff you know but is is there
parkour elements no there's no problem
nowhere it's a rounded typical it's a
very grounded like it it's Dead Island
one but Dead Island two well